hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and I just came back from the dev
stream we're gonna be doing the dev shoe
recap like we always do every Thursday
we got some information to talk about a
new open test for all platforms like its
normal pts but for everybody
patch 1.17 is so it's gonna be
chock-full with some information so
what's I'm wasting time and let's get
started so first up for the for honor
open test dedicated servers it's on the
PTR or the pts whatever they happen to
call it it used to be only on PC for PC
but now it is for Xbox and ps4 they
managed to get it for all consoles or
all platforms which is amazing
you could have pre downloaded this
yesterday and then got to play today or
you could download it today and play it
today it didn't matter I was going to
announce it but then it would have been
its own separate video and it really
wouldn't have made sense and I wanted to
fit it in with today along with patch
1.17 so I'm gonna be showing you some
on-screen images from their Twitter on
what the open test dedicated server is
going to be about so basically on the
first thing we're seeing is an emblem
symbol and this is the emblem symbol
that we're going to get if you
participate in the open test you're just
going to receive one exclusive emblem
and at the bottom you're going to have
daily order completion rewards this is
to get players the to give players the
incentive of actually playing so it says
play eight players in the open test will
receive following in-game rewards upon
the completion of daily orders two daily
orders is 2,000 stable for scavenger
crates for date for daily orders is
4,000 steel and eight scavenger crates
six daily orders is 6000 steel 12 crates
and three days of champion status and
then eight daily orders is 8,000 steel
16 crates and seven days of champion
status the rewards are going to be
giving to us on the 20th I don't
remember the exact date but I believe
that might be Wednesday I think and I do
believe that the open test ends Monday
so it's basically going to be a weekend
thing so if you want a loads of extra
steel champion status crates all that
good stuff
definitely hop on this open test on the
weekend next up is a raffle participants
in the open desk will be eligible for
the open test raffle and you can see the
Official Rules if you are eligible but
to participate you basically just as a
complete daily orders like we talked
about so on top of the fact that you are
getting those steal those scavenger
crates and the champion says for doing
those orders if you get two daily orders
you get five entries 15
thirty inches 50 entries all that stuff
and if you do have a bunch of entries
you have the option of getting or you
have the chance of earning a apollyon
statue a season three faction more
winners t-shirt a signed copy of for
honor sign concept are a year of
champion status a hundred dollars in
steel packs or a one or a signed feast
of the over or the of the other world
poster so that there's a lot of items I
think but I believe that's like 31
different things so about 31 winners are
gonna be winning across stall platform
so definitely do those eight daily
rewards to get the maximum of entries
possible and then maybe you can win some
and then lastly is the community order
completion rewards now obviously every
week at our just about every weekend we
get it we get a community order that we
can complete so it's gonna be a bit
different this time so the order is as a
community play target matches to earn
main game rewards I'm assuming that just
playing matches on PC the ticket to 100%
you have to get six six hundred sixty
thousand ps4 is 1.5 mil and an Xbox one
it's one point seven mil
balance it out between the each console
you know the consoles having more
players than PC and all that stuff but
regardless if you complete 25% of the
gold and you'll get 1,000 steal for
everyone on your platform if you if the
community completes 50% they'll get an
emblem outlined on top of the steel
alright you'll also get 2,000 - I should
say if you get 75% you'll get 3,000
steal the emblem outline and a melee
pack which is three years of champion
status and one scavenger crate but and
then if you get one hundred percent for
your platform you're gonna be getting
four thousand steel emblem outline a
melee pack and a Kombat pack which comes
with ten days of champion status and
three scavenger crates together so
entirely this whole open test you need
to take advantage of you're gonna get if
you do all the daily orders and if you
complete this thing you're gonna be
getting like 16,000 steal tons of
scavenger creates tons of champion
status you're gonna be rolling in it
so this is definitely one thing you do
want to take advantage of while it's
available and like I said the thing is
actually able to be downloaded today and
you could play today and get immediately
on that I'm going to be doing that as
soon as this video is uploaded which it
obviously is if you're if you're
watching this but to continue now we
have patch 1.17 so let's go
started with that so I just want to
start off before we say this and say
that there's a lot of patches in this
it's mostly bug fixes but there are a
few things worth noting if you do want
to keep track or read all of it it'll be
the first link in the description it'll
lead to the reddit post where I'm
reading this from and you could follow
along with me or read it or you could
read all of it it's completely up to you
but to start predators hunger predators
mercy and wild cats rage for the shaman
now have reduced ability to attract
two-track opponents this was a problem
when it was when people would be tracked
around corners if you cancel predators
hunger predators mercy and wild cats
rage into combat Idol which is just
normally fainting it would be it is now
being increased stamina for 24 instead
of 10 and predators hunger predators
mercy Wildcats rage not 100 millisecond
shorter windows to cancel the strike the
reason that they did this is that so
people would commit to the moves more
instead of just continuously fainting
them to throw off their opponents
predators hunger and predators mercy
attack strike range is being slightly
reduced and there's a lot of bug fixes
with her so clearly there's a lot of bug
fixes for the rest of these characters
just about every single character
roughly got a bug fix so I'm gonna be
going through these and I'm only going
to be picking out the most important
ones and once again you can just click
the top link in the description and read
all of them for your specific character
if I did miss any of them one of the
issues is that it fixed an issue that
could prevent players from climbing up
ladders Valkyries no touching execution
is now being added into the game there
was a problem with the audio for it so
that it's now back in the game for all
you Valkyrie mains you can now rejoice
that you have your new execution again
Centurion stamina cost of punch after a
heavy finisher will now correctly cost
12 stamina it was originally 16 and when
performed after line fangs and lion bite
combos and that was about it I know
there is tons of bug fixes that are in
this patch once again just click that
link and you'll be taken right to it
there are so many bug fixes and I don't
want to make this video longer than it
has to be it would be like a 15 minute
video and I'm not trying to sit in here
and boring you with the constant this
issue is fixed or the issue is fixed so
either way just click the link and you
can look at it for your specific main or
if you want to look at all the other
heroes you can do so there's a lot to go
over either way there's a lot of bug
fixes meaning that they are aware of
these and it's going to be
then this game is gonna be more polished
which is a good thing and anyway guys
with that being said that's going to be
the end of the video if you did like the
video please sort of give it a like it
really does help me out and subscribe if
you're new too for honor I talked about
the discussion the leaks the news
anything regarding the informational
side of for honor I always keep
everybody up to date everybody knows
what I do and while you're at it hit
that Bell right next to it just so that
you can be notified of whenever I post
the video become part of the
notification squad and get updates on my
post on the community tab and then when
I start streaming like I said I'm gonna
be strive like I said last week I was
gonna be streaming I'm definitely going
to be streaming the open test this
weekend so please be sure to be on the
lookout for that stream come say hi all
that good stuff
my two most recent videos were popping
up on screen I can't put the stream on
screen it does not allow me to but if
you do want to check out the stream from
last week it was a pretty good time I
had a ton of fun with you guys a lot of
you came out I do appreciate that so
shout out to any of you guys that did
come out I had a lot of fun so once
again if you do want to check those
videos out they'll be up there and with
that guys I hope you have a great rest
your day and peace out